who i guess you know was at mit at the
time but is now at stanford so please
take it away
thanks this is the joint work with ragu
who i guess really just spoke
uh john kellner and dhruv rohatki
who is a graduate student at mit
okay i thought yeah since uh we talked
about something that's kind of related
i'll start with you know resetting our
minds by thinking about just general
machine learning very quickly so
you guys probably heard of this thing
called supervised learning is kind of
the best and what is this concept of
supervised learning it was you have the
training data and you have the test data
right and
i observe pairs x y which are the
training data and generally speaking you
think of the x as like i don't know for
example the image and why is some kind
of label and you want to learn to
predict the label why or the response
lie if you use
uh you want to learn to predict that
given the x
and what does it mean to do learning
it's like you can get a small error on
the test set and so this is just like a
very
you know this is our standard
mathematical formula for supervised
learning which i just thought i'll
remind you of because this talk is about
supervised learning
um so basically we want to learn a
function that gets a small error on the
test set
okay and then when you start to think
about the theory of learning
you have this kind of there's a bit of a
caricature but you have this kind of
funny thing which happens is that the
problems are often like very hard or
very easy so this is like an example so
it's not important to
understand this example deeply for the
top
but just think about the simplest
machine learning models maybe half-based
learning so you have a bunch of data and
you want to find a linear half space
that does a good job of predicting you
know plus versus minus or cats versus
docs
and we know that like there exists some
situation so the distribution d
um from which the examples are taken
from
where there's a half space
which is extremely good but you just
cannot possibly find it there's an
efficient algorithm unless you are going
to like break some
widely expected conjectures in like
cryptography
so that's a result of danielle and so
when you see that you're like okay
whatever like that's not the real world
so like it's fine so then you might
write down a model and you're like okay
well maybe the data is from a gaussian
then also maybe for simplicity the data
is like 100 linearly separable
that's not so important but anyway if
you are going to make that kind of
modeling assumption all of a sudden the
problem goes from being like super duper
hard to being super duper easy and like
any algorithm you think of that is
vaguely reasonable would solve that
problem
and so it's kind of disappointing since
this is the algorithms workshop if that
was the algorithm because you would
think we have to think hard and come up
with a good algorithm
and so
uh this is like a you know what kind of
situations might we actually need to
think hard and come up with good
algorithms
well one situation is like the data's
not like totally trivial like this id
gaussian entries
um but it's also not adversarial of
course that's like lots of things
um so like more specifically of course
since this is kind of like the causality
workshop maybe we should assume we have
some kind of understanding for example
of the causal structure so you might
um i guess
if you went through the causality boot
camp you learned about structural
equation models which
are i guess basically they include more
information than a gaussian graphical
model but
in particular if there's a simple
structural equation model it arises
gives rise basically to some kind of
simple gaussian graphical model so some
kind of model like that standard
graphical mode and uh of course then
okay now this is a interesting data
maybe
you know can we still learn when the
data is drawn from this kind of
interesting distribution and that's what
this talk is about
okay and then uh okay you can forget
about all that if you didn't like it but
we're going to talk about one of the
most classic and fundamental problems in
high dimensional statistics which is the
sparse linear regression
and uh
i guess what are we going to do we're
going to explain that this is a
situation where the
it's not like the okay the standard
algorithm for this problem as far as
linear aggression is lasso like ragu
mentioned and that's not like a trivial
algorithm that's a very smart algorithm
but nevertheless it fails and i'm going
to explain how to fix it and what's
going on with this
okay
so i thought i'll review the background
although i'm sure lots of people have
learned about this
but yeah let me be very clear so this is
a precise mod so
i have
independent samples from a gaussian and
what's really important now is that the
covariance matrix sigma is a general
covariance
so oftentimes you would study it in the
case where the x i's are normal zero i
um that's a very standard theoretical
model and that will be much easier than
the case of a general covariance sigma
and then what we observe uh
you know it's just a standard high
dimensional linear model just like also
in the dd's talk
you observe the dot product of the data
with some unknown vector which i'm
calling wsr
and uh as far as linear regression so
that vector is sparse
okay and uh this is of course a
classical model which has like tons of
applications in different areas like i
don't know bio such as biostatistics or
compressed sensing
so i won't go into the applications also
i'll use this notation which is very
standard which is just write everything
with matrices just so it's a little
cleaner so y is like a vector with all
the responses x is a matrix where the
rows are the covariates and you know
just by the definition of matrix
multiplication this is the same model
and uh
exactly as i was describing before the
goal is to learn to predict the whys
from the excise and the really the
really important thing that ragu you
know i see us emphasizing his talk we
want to do it with very few samples
right because in many of these like
scientific applications you don't get
very much data okay so that's this is
what we want to do
um unfortunately
uh okay like we could do it in the full
generality but all the ideas i can
explain in the case where there's no
noise uh so i'll just do that there's
not gonna be any noise in this
presentation but obviously we read the
favor everything you know works and
all the full generality that you might
like like noise and misspecification so
it's not actually generated from a model
like this
so all of that stuff is fine and i'm
just going to consider the simplest case
so that we can
we can focus on the core ideas and if
the sigma
the covariance is invertible which i'll
assume
the goal is really just i observe x
times w star and i want to exactly
recover w star so that's the
statistically optimal thing you want to
do
okay and like i like okay we know this
is like a really classic problem in high
dimensional statistics what's perhaps
the most well-known algorithm for this
problem would be the lasso
and the lasso is it's just like the
ordinary least squares estimator so you
try to find
something which approximately
solves the equation y equals xw and you
put in this l1 penalty which
and there's some idea that the l1 norm
encourages varsity and that's
that's uh i guess it goes back to the
80s and geostatistics they realized like
oh yeah there is something where l1 norm
can really help with sparsity
and it spawned this whole area
of studying l1 penalized regression
okay now in the noiseless case it's even
simpler so because there's no noise i
know i really want to get a solution x w
equals y
and uh
you know i will try to minimize the l1
norm as a proxy for sparse p so
basically i'm trying to find the sparse
solution to this set of linear equations
there are so many other estimators for
this like the the slope the elastic net
the
orthogonal matching pursuit which ragu
mentioned so i'm not going to get into
all the details but you know a very
large class of these algorithms are
based off this idea of l1 as a as a
proxy for sparsity and so if that's the
case then just considering the lasso you
know is pretty representative
okay now
what is the classical guarantee you can
find in the high dimensional statistics
textbook
is that this algorithm like the the
lasso it works um really really well
if the condition number is bounded so
uh you can look at slightly more precise
notions of what is a condition number
but basically look at the maximum and
the minimum
eigenvalue of sigma and look at the
ratio if it's if it's bounded by a
constant then lasso or basis pursuits
they work almost as well as the
information certificate optimal
estimator so they'll get exact recovery
uh from k log n samples and the sample
complexity will blow up polynomially
with the condition number
okay
now on the other hand also what we know
is that uh there's actually no reason
for that to happen like information
theoretically no matter what the sigma
is as long as it's invertible you should
be able to exactly recover the w star so
i'm going to generate this random system
of equations and like you know for sure
like once there's like k log n samples
you can uniquely recover the solution to
that
if you're willing to search over all
sparse vectors and
of course the only problem is that it's
like becomes extremely computationally
expensive because it requires runtime
like n is a k i'm sorry like i guess i
should have mentioned i'm using the
different notation
unfortunately from ragu so n is actually
the number of variables
k is varsity so n is a k that's that's
very
bad not really practical unless k is
like two or three okay
and um
other hand what else do we know there's
one more algorithm we could consider
which is if you have a linear system at
some point it just started to have a
unique solution
once you have the
number of observations is at least as
big as the number of variables you could
just solve the linear system and that
will recover w star
and uh you know we know that the best
thing would have like log n dependence
and this thing has a dependence that is
like n so it's an exponentially
sub-optimal uh algorithm
okay
and so because okay there's like some
create very large gap with this people
have tried really hard to understand
what's going on
um so i can't actually really
give a full survey of all the work
people try to do to explain what's going
on here
um but maybe the high level summary is
that we know that if you pick a worse
set case set of linear equations and
promise me there is a smart solution and
i try to find it in general that's empty
hard that's
it's not super hard to prove that's
empty hard and so you can try to push on
this and like understand what other
consequences this has and you can get
hardness for
you know
some non-obvious generalizations of that
problem um
on the other hand there's some other
pressure from the other direction so you
cannot really get or we don't expect you
can actually get hardness for the
problem as i formulated it
because it is a supervised learning
problem there's all these obstructions
to proving hardness of learning so
um and it has to do with also the
problem of like constructing
cryptography from worst case assumptions
so there's there's some non-trivial
reason that we don't expect you could
push that all the way
uh to empty hardness towards this
problem
and finally
um because we don't have that kind of
tool we also know examples in previous
work where the lasso fails so for
example if you start to scale the
variables in a very bad way like
half the variables are multiplied by 10
million and half of them are divided by
10 million that can really cause
problems for lasso
but also that's very easy to fix you
just rescale everything by so that like
the coordinates have unit variance and
then that would not be a problem anymore
so interestingly although we think it's
hard we don't really have very clear
examples that we think are really really
hard for this problem
and so for a reminder of this talk that
was a background
i'm going to return to the same example
ragu mentioned but now i'm trying to do
sparse linear aggression over it's a
random walk and it turns out the whole
series is going to be different
than what ragu talked about okay
um
i guess i just put in a picture of the
random walk so you can visualize it and
this is the notation i'm using r i or rt
is is the value of the random lock at
time i
and every time i add a gaussian and
that's that's my model
um
the actual algorithm i'm going to
explain is going to work for much more
general like if you have like an auto
regressive time series
if you enter that kind of thing or
multiple auto regressive time series the
actual algorithm is going to work for
all of those so this is just a
representative of like the simplest kind
of time series model
and we we know and we've pointed out in
a work of kolchinsky and minsker that uh
this thing is uh really seems nasty for
sparsely regression because it's badly
ill-conditioned so our classical theory
doesn't work very well
and like ragu explained we have
algorithms to learn this kind of
gaussian graphical model from data
but
it doesn't solve this problem that i'm
talking about now as far as linear
regression where the data is from that
distribution so
i won't say anything else about that but
if you want to ask more like how's it
compare like i'm happy to answer
questions
okay and then here i you know just run
an experiment make sure that the lasso
doesn't actually work
um so bp is basically pursuit so that's
the noiseless version of lasso
and uh depending on exactly how you
define the algorithm um probably the red
line is more representative actually of
the lasso
uh
blue line is lasso and i just there's a
difference in scaling between those two
lines but either way you do it uh as you
do the simulations it's clear that the
sample complexity of the lasso is
scaling like square root n and also in
our paper we prove the lower bound so
if you if you do sparse linear
regression over
this data distribution
our favorite algorithm the lasso doesn't
really work very well
and of course you see there's this black
line which is way better which is the
precondition basis pursuit and that's
what i'll explain
okay
now preconditioning
um of course that's like one of the our
most favorite things is algorithm people
so it's an extremely important tool for
solving linear systems in practice
and um
what we're doing now is trying to see if
we can use this uh basically to save us
in samples instead of in runtime
okay so
uh this is kind of a silly thing but you
know i have this equation y equals x w
star and i want to figure out how to
pre-condition it well i can just
multiply by a matrix s transpose and
it's inverse
and obviously that equation is still
true
and so based on that um
you know i'm just going to do the same
thing as basis pursuit which is analyze
the l1 norm
uh but i'm going to penalize the l1 norm
of s transpose w1
and then if you think about it for a
moment it's like literally the same
thing if s is invertible as i first
change basis by s and then i run the
basis pursuit so you know i guess
depending on which way you like to think
about it it's exactly basis pursuit
after change of basis
or you could think this s transpose w
one norm this is some proxy for sparsity
i'm trying to propose that it's actually
a better proxy for sparsity than the
normal l1
so either way you want to think about it
okay
now how could we precondition the random
walks we saw the basis pursuit clearly
didn't work
what's the most obvious thing okay well
we know the problem is that the
condition number of the random walk is
huge so what could you do is you could
look at the step basis so instead of
looking at the actual random walk look
at the difference between the random
walk at time i and time i minus one
and those are a bunch of independent
gaussians so we fixed the condition
number perfectly uh the condition number
is one
now
uh the random walk
let's just write out the change of basis
so a random walk is a sum of steps
and so if we look at an example like
this so the signal is just random market
time one plus random walk at time
thousand
what happens when i make the change of
bases well it's really bad actually
right because
i plug in my change of basis so delta r
1000 is delta 1 plus dot dot plus delta
1000
and so this is my new linear regression
model in the step basis and what's the
problem it's not sparse anymore right
um and if if you're trying to recover
something that's not sparse we know
actually basis pursuit will never work
okay
and so
that's really bad you actually made the
problem much worse by doing that change
of basis okay
so now we have to think a little more
like
so the most obvious thing didn't work
what is the correct thing to do
okay
and now this is a thing that of course
is so important in this area is
basically the markov property
maybe i'll just
draw on the board
you know here's my simple random walk so
it looks very complicated but
if i
look here's you know time
zero here's time t here's time t over
two
then actually
left
is independent of the right
uh
given
i guess i'm using this r
r t over two so
if you look at this model it's sort of
as soon as i condition on this one thing
it basically just simplifies to two
smaller random walks and
you know maybe you would imagine like
doing that kind of recursively
maybe that's going to be a good idea
and in fact that's that's what's going
to work
um
okay yeah so it's just an example you
know maybe closer to the way you're
normally taught about the markov
property you're trying to predict the
random walk at time 150
given the observations from 1 to 100 the
only thing that's relevant
is at time 100 and that's you know just
an example of this conditional
independence problem and i guess this is
the kind of property you would use to
argue you can't make money
gambling on it
okay
and so you think about this and what you
do this is actually in this example is
exactly the change of basis you do it
looks really complicated
but really all i did is i built a tree
where i put the middle vertex at the top
and then on the left and right i put the
middle of the left segment and middle of
the right segment and so on recursively
i put it all in a tree that's the left
picture
and then in the right picture for every
variable i subtract it off
um
it's an expectation conditional on all
of its parents
okay so
basically as i i did not explain all the
details the markov property i was
talking about here is exactly saying
that when i go to the right picture uh
all of those random variables they're
actually all independent so i perfectly
fixed the condition number
and
because of the way i defined it
you can see that every variable on the
right sort of
could be
okay let's say i want to write down the
original variable x1 so i need this
change of basis to be sparsity
preserving but then when you think about
it the variable on the left x1 can be
written as a sum of a small number of
variables on the right
[Music]
so it exactly can be written in terms of
the variables on the path to that node
um and so this tree is a binary tree
that's balanced it has log n depth so
you only lose a log factor in sparsity
so that's the trick it
fixes the
fixes both the conditioning problem and
it preserves varsity and that's exactly
what i use to generate the plot
okay and
just using your standard analysis of the
lasso
if you use the change of basis then the
lasso works really well and you get a
recovery with k log squared and samples
now fortunately uh
i think you guys have heard about this
probably at least twice probably many
more times so there's a markov property
in general
and so this whole thing wasn't really
about the random walk what was it about
it was about i was able to find
something that really simplified the
model
um
okay formalism is the markov random
field or undirected graphical model
markov property says if i look at a
variable it's conditionally independent
of everything else given the neighbors
random walk like we saw
you know it's just an example of this
phenomenon where the graph of the path
uh in general gaussian graphical models
like rogue said
your dependency graph is a non-zero
pattern of inverse covariance
and finally since this is the workshop
on causality if you have a directed
graphical model you probably know that
there's a simple relation between that
and it's undirected structure which is
called the moral graph so
if you know that this thing is generated
by directed models and there's an easy
way to go to the undirected version
okay
and this is just like the you know how
do we formalize what what do we really
need
what we needed is that there was a small
set of things that i could use to break
apart the model into two independent
parts
and so graph theoretically what is this
is this well-known concept of tree with
and so it's just saying i mean you can
here's a notation but it's just saying
i've got the whole graph i can find this
small set a and then it splits the graph
into two independent parts p and q so
they're literally not connected so
another way to say all the paths from p
to q pass through a
and then low tree width is basically
saying you have this property and you
can also apply it recursively okay so
again you know let's not worry about the
notation too much but just a very
natural generalization of what i did
here
that's actually going to work for any
low tree with graph so i just keep
breaking apart the graph recursively
this gives me a better choice of
variables to do the basis pursuit in
and you pay a
loss in the sparsity of true width times
log dimension
okay
and if you think about this a little
more this is like as far as linear
regression analog of something very
famous in numerical linear algebra
which is called a generalized nested
dissection method
so the exact facts we use about um
like this recursive
decomposition is also useful for solving
linear systems we're using it in a bit
different way but it is this really
classical and important idea
okay and so just yeah use your favorite
theorem about the lasso you'll get
recovery from like
uh sparsity times tree width times log
squared and samples if the dependency
graph has tree with t
so that's great uh everything yeah works
like you expect in the noisy in the
specified case
okay now as i specified it
like um you saw like i had the left
picture in the right picture
i don't know the preconditioner does
depend on sigma it kind of makes sense
right like
if i scale things the preconditioner
needs to unscale them so
as i described it the algorithm needs to
see the true covariance matrix sigma
which may not seem like such a
reasonable assumption but what is a
reasonable assumption is that you know
the dependency graph
and then with a sufficient amount of
pain you can prove that even with a very
small number of samples you can replace
the true sigma by the empirical
covariance matrix and you can actually
still construct the pre-condition
so like uh
it's kind of non-obvious because the
empirical covariance from few samples is
actually a pretty poor estimate of the
true covariance matrix but because we
only care about its behavior as far as
vectors once you do it all out it
actually works okay so you don't need to
know anything except the graph
um
you know and i guess i already mentioned
this but like very important examples of
models uh you know high dimensional uh
distributions which would have
obviously low truth with would be like a
linear dynamical system which is also if
you think about it basically the same
thing as the multiple autoregressive
models
and of course yeah low tree waste is has
always been a very important concept in
graphical models
you know we use it in totally other
contexts like the junction tree
algorithm
okay
um
yeah okay so
we saw all of this
it was great it depended on the tree
with t
and now i want to explain that in some
sense this algorithm is basically
optimal
um
so what do i mean obviously i can't
prove mp hardness or something right so
it's going to be in a pretty restricted
sense so i'm going to show that for
preconditioning the lasso or basis
pursuit this approach is basically
optimal
okay and
the way to do this is well first
start thinking about what kind of graphs
have high tree with
if you know what expander graph is
expanded graphs then we have very high
tree with something that's kind of in
between would be a grid graph um or this
is a grid graph with triangles
so a grid graph has uh due to this thing
called the planar separator theorem
uh has a tree with like square root n
which is good because that means you get
something non-trivial from our result
you say from n to square root n the
sample complexity
but has a relatively high tree width
and you might wonder okay can you do a
lot better
than square root n for this kind of
graph
and what i'm going to tell you is you
cannot do that much better so you can
perhaps go from like square root n to
like enter the 1 over 100 or something
so we didn't fully optimize
the dependence but for any
tree with t graph there's just no way to
do a preconditioner that's gonna get you
a sample complexity that's better than
omega polyt okay
and so i'm not just saying like there
are some high tree with graphs that are
bad literally for any high truest
graph i can come up with a gaussian
random field on it such that
you can't precondition it
okay
now
i'm not going to go
into all the details of this proof but
if maybe if there's one
technical
cool technical result that you take away
independent of the content of this talk
you might learn that there's this thing
called the polynomial grid minor theorem
and you know this is one of the key
technical ingredients and
what it's saying is it's basically a
structure serum for low tree with graphs
so any graph which has tree with t
the reason that it has large tree widths
can be certified by finding this thing
called a grid minor so a grid miner is
basically an embedding of the square
grid graph into
the overall graph
okay so a little more precisely a minor
is formed by deleting edges deleting
vertices or contracting edges so setting
the two endpoints equal
okay so that's that's a really great
result and all of a sudden this gives us
i mean you can imagine it would be very
hard to prove this theorem to just do
something for all graphs but this tells
us that actually tree was load high tree
with graphs have a nice structure okay
so once we know that there's a grid
minor
you can with some effort reduced to
constructing a bad example on the square
grid like i was talking about
now we need another technical ingredient
which is how do you actually prove the
lasso fails so mostly people are
positive so they try to prove lasso
succeeds um so there wasn't quite the
right technology in the literature to
prove
uh like a condition that implies lasso
fails um
but we we do construct this and
basically we show that a variant of this
thing called a compatibility condition
which is like
basically the the more precise
definition of well-conditioned matrix
such that lasso succeeds is really
necessary and so now we have an easy to
use condition to prove that lasso fails
and all you need to do then is construct
the code variants so that no matter
how you use as far as how no matter how
you change basis like basically you
either blow up the sparsity
um or you don't do a very good job of
preconditioning okay and when you look
into all the technical details like
basically you want to construct a matrix
which has this very large uh top eigen
space
which is full of dense vectors
and
basically that's this obstruction that
no matter how i multiply by as far as
matrices i just can't fix
okay
uh then you need to do on a grid graph
which itself is kind of tricky so i'll
just say like what you do is basically
do some kind of gadget construction to
reduce from the grid graph to something
that's kind of like an expander graph
and then
on an expander graph
you can actually almost literally take
a random
deregular graph adjacency matrix and
invert it and um that more or less uh
works okay so there there's a lot that
i'm hiding there but that's kind of the
high level idea is that there's just
some obstructions that as far as
preconditioners can't fix and as a
consequence we really don't have any
technique to solve those models okay
uh and so it leaves open of course a
very important question which is
okay are those models really hard or
maybe we just need new algorithmic ideas
um i don't know um
okay and relatedly like you know in real
life maybe it's high tree width but you
have other information that you can use
to construct even you know a smarter
algorithm than just preconditioned lasso
uh to solve um sparsely regression so
that's very interesting
um of course you know at the beginning i
was talking like we're going to use
information about maybe it's a causal
structure or other kind of structure
to construct really sample efficient
algorithms why should this be limited
only to sparse linear regression
and
finally for people who really like
statistics
you can actually improve the log factors
using this sophisticated scheme called
pre-structured iterative hard
thresholding
so some kind of smart non-convex
optimization um
and it would be really interesting um
actually to understand the precise
sample complexities that you get in high
dimensions so this is
a kind of a different direction from
computational complexity but also i
think would be interesting okay that's
it so thanks for listening
[Applause]
all right quick question or two before
the break
all right so let's thank freddie again
and we'll take any other questions off